you know they say truth is Stranger Than
Fiction
well this is nominees for best
documentary told stories that you really
could not make up with an emotional
rawness that most fiction can only
really aspire to and be inspired by and
you know what I mean I gotta say I loved
your documentary last year like this
year's nominees it yeah thank you
I love you
but it was like Lord these nominees told
an amazing Untold Story
thank you man uh you know we're making a
documentary using never before seen
footage it gives New Life a new meaning
and it's just one of the techniques used
by these documentarians basically uh
others use archival photographs or in
innovative ways or spent years following
their subjects both animal and human
right but no matter what the approach
these filmmakers capture these Universal
truths through such unique stories
whether it was about orphanages or
political dissidents injured Birds
groundbreaking artists and even volcano
chasing lovers
and what brought these stories to life
on screen are these filmmakers unique
lenses and points of view so here are
the nominees for best documentary
feature film all the breeds Sean accent
Aman man and Teddy lifa all the Beauty
and the Bloodshed Laura poitrus Howard
gertler John Lyons Nan Goldie and Yoni
golihov fire of love Sarah Dosa Shane
Boris and Aina fitchman a house made of
splinters Simon Lorraine Wilmont and
Monica hellstrom navalny Daniel Roar
Odessa Ray Diane Becker Melanie Miller
and Shane Boris
and the Oscar goes to
navalny
Diane Becker Melanie Miller and Shane
Boris
director Daniel Rohr and his team filmed
Alexei navalny while he was in fighting
from the Russian government at a remote
location in Germany
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you to the academy
we are humbled to be in the company of
such an extraordinary crop of
documentary filmmakers these films
redefined what it is to be a naked
documentary
to everyone who helped make our film you
know who you are your bravery and
courage
made this film possible
we owe so much
to our Bulgarian nerd with a laptop
Crystal grosev
Christo you risk everything to tell this
story and it's investigative journalists
like you and Maria pebcik that Empower
our work
to the navalny family
Yulia Dasha and zahar thank you for your
courage the world is with you
and there's one person who couldn't be
with us here tonight
Alexei navalny the leader of the Russian
opposition
remains in solitary confinement for what
he calls I want to make sure we get his
words exactly right Vladimir Putin's
unjust war of aggression in Ukraine I
would like to dedicate this award to
navalny to all political prisoners
around the world Alexei the world has
not forgotten your vital message to us
all we cannot we must not be afraid to
oppose dictators and authoritarianism
wherever it rears its head I want to
invite Yulia to say a few quick remarks
Julia
thank you Daniel and thank you to every
everybody here my husband is in prison
just for telling the truth my husband is
in prison just for
defending democracy
uh Alexey
I am dreaming the day when you will be
free
and our country will be free uh
stay strong my love thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]